hi everybody this is jonathan trance and  i have yet another tactical challenge  for you so when you see the position on  your screen go ahead and pause the video  and we'll see if you can solve it in  this position it's black to move are you  ready for the solution in this position  black can win in three moves the first  move is Bishop to e3 now white can  respond in two different ways if he  plays King to h1 black simply plays  Bishop takes g2 and it's checkmate if on  the other hand white decides to block  with the rook now black mates with the  move rook to a1 the Ruka spins so it can  only block with a bishop to avoid mate  for one more move and after a rook takes  Bishop we have checkmate  black wins the game I hope you enjoyed  this video congratulations to everybody  that was able to get this one right and  we'll see you again later for another  tactical challenge and if you want to  see more of this content hit subscribe  to our YouTube channel and thank you for  watching